I've never seen a real UFO video I think
they're all fake but I believe there
could be a second layer for what we're
about to watch today
Because deep down I truly want to
believe we all want to see something
unexplainable are these plausibly
something unexplained is somebody faking
it or is it just a trick of the lens
let's see what we got
[Music]
U.S military drone captures video
orb-like objects okay there we go that
isn't our black object I mean this
straight up just looks like a balloon
there's a moment there where it looks
like the classic like latex balloon sir
are you seeing this okay this reminds me
a lot of the other videos we saw which
is an object flying in a straight line
at like seemingly crazy speeds the
airplane itself is flying at a great
speed in a direction like you know 300
miles an hour potentially anything you
see from this perspective it's going to
travel against the plane of the ground
it's a classic Michael Bay shot so he's
got the camera whipping along you're
looking at somebody standing there and
the background's just a big motion blur
it's the sun sets and there's a robot
this is the same effect but you're even
further back and you're going even
faster and the camera zoomed in even
more so as the drones following it
hitting this big sweep across the
background as it's kind of just locked
onto this balloon as it's flying past it
that looks like a balloon to me it's a
balloon I think we bunked this one
pretty hard we debunked it we debunked
it to Bunk it is actually to prove it's
real my bad all the orb videos I've seen
up this point they look exactly like
this thing flying never changes
directions it's always in a straight
line because it's being filmed from an
airplane Which flies in a straight line
you see something like soup
that's where you go whoa that's not a
trick of perspective but we haven't seen
a single one of those
another orb
foreign
I think this is visual effects what are
the telltale signs that say this is a
visual effect first and most foremost
overcast day yet we're getting
directional Lighting on one side of it
that makes no sense I think this is a
classic case of VFX because of the
Telltale highlight going gray as it goes
behind the cloud we should see that hot
spots shrink to just a little dot of the
Sun and then disappear the clouds should
be acting like an ND filter that is just
stopping down the
bring the exposure down and you'll see
the paper start becoming gray and then
darker but this flashlight is going to
stay bright the whole time but instead
what we're seeing is the same size of
that white spot just get dimmer which
isn't how Optics work and it turns gray
it doesn't necessarily Fade to like a
blue or other Sky color it's just the
Overexposed value being brought down
they did a really nice job tracking it
getting the Jitter of the camera
matching the grain masking the clouds
that flies behind them but it's those
hdri highlights that that give it away
from me fake all right hit me with
another one maybe the next one will be
really nice
exclusive footage from Kaden and Kelly
little lights will quickly zoom off to
the left of your screen and then they
just disappear oh come on
they sent the effects to the local news
station all right Caden awesome I love
like the mysterious like spinning object
you got very classic saucer UFO you know
I love they have two angles which is
amazing that's great but I can still
tell it's like you and your buddy camera
starts to pan left at the exact same
time the UFO starts to move it's always
that staged handheld motion let's do a
test here's my finger I'd like you to
follow it I'm gonna move it this way are
you ready here we go
[Music]
I was expecting you to go the other way
they should have probably let it keep
going just a little bit longer because
it cuts immediately the moment it flies
off and it's like in real life if you're
recording that whoa you'd still be
searching for it yeah go into After
Effects take that handle
and just get like render us another four
or five seconds why not yeah and there's
one last thing same with the orb yeah
you didn't quite hit the HDR highlights
when it flies away those lights they got
to be brighter streaks if you would have
done that would have been perfect next
time you do this you're going to want to
set after effects to 32-bit okay do a
little multiplication a little division
on your motion blur this is just a
couple little secrets and tips there to
actually get photoreal motion blur in
After Effects next time
oh whoa whoa that's the thing the guy
just flew back that definitely looks
like some sort of mylar balloon the hot
spot on it is like out of focus causing
that like bokeh shape balloon balloon
balloon we gotta find the stats are
there more birthday parties happening
today than planes in the sky there are
approximately 22 million birthdays per
day and then let's just say one percent
of these birthdays are careless
these are the Rowdy ones the parents
aren't paying attention the balloons are
not tied tightly we could be looking at
22 000 mylar balloons being released
accidentally into the sky every day
which is more than the amount of weather
balloons plus commercial flights being
launched at any given moment a balloon
in a plane crossing paths is nothing
unusual
Nick Nick down here oh hey you hear them
talking about orbs up there it's all
about the circles right now none of it's
true if you want something you can
believe in if you want something out of
this world what you need to look for are
squares specifically today's sponsor
Squarespace people spend all this time
obsessing over these orb videos these
UFO videos and what do they get in
return nothing look at the screen you're
watching this on right now and tell me
that orbs are the truth okay look are
you are is your is your screen circular
or is it square with Squarespace you get
everything you need you see they allow
you to build an entire online store
including but not limited to having your
own merchandise that you can sell
directly to your visitors and to all
you can track your data from your site
directly to the best in-game analytics
that Squarespace has allowing you to
better build and form your website so
that you get more customers
and more visitors so if you're
interested in getting started today with
your own Squarespace website head on
over to squarespace.com Corner crew and
you get 10 of your first purchase of a
website or domain squarespace.com
if I gotta get back to work serious get
out of here this is not a weather
balloon that's a mylar balloon this time
a balloon Jesus Christ is Jason balloon
wait that's just oh wait that's an emoji
never mind
is this in camera or is this a visual
effect
I think this is an edit I think we're
looking at a balloon and I think we have
something cut to an airplane formation
and it cuts back to this footage yes
also if those are jets by the way yes
that's going to show up in the audio
chat sorry super loud Christian he plays
with sound let's see if we can hear the
planes from the beginning
fake from the tone of the voice alone
next metal sphere flying in Warsaw
Poland high quality photos in post so
this is something somebody got
exposure matches black levels Match
Light Direction matches I'm not getting
VFX vibes from this this looks like it's
real captured in camera can you search
real quick for black weather balloons
because I think you can get those yeah I
mean um that picture looks exactly like
what was filmed it doesn't move in a
straight line which is a little weird
but like it's not like it changed
directions it's curving so gradually
that can easily be explained by I mean
we've all seen balloons like get lost
and go up into the sky it looks like
that you're right it looks exactly like
that I got a hint of thrill but it was
quickly dashed much more plausibly a
balloon than an alien it's a balloon
looks like a still image in the
background those clouds aren't moving at
all it's hard to tell because the
compression is really really bad like
look at the iframe drop on it these
people who like find these things are
really doing themselves a disservice
when they don't upload it you know in a
decent quality are they I think the the
degraded quality is really kind of part
of the Mystique around UFO videos it's
like a myth right it's a legend it's a
digital Legend SV downloaded and
re-encoded and re-uploaded so many times
the story slowly evolves the pixels
slowly evolve into other shapes so I did
see the clouds moving in the very end of
this and I hate to say it
that balloon is sure flying in a
straight line isn't it
my balloons if only there is a thing
that
see a circle
floating in a gentle Direction at a
straight line like
balloon is the first thing that comes to
my mind and I don't know why that's not
the person that comes to everybody
else's mind when they see this
because they want to believe I know I
want to believe too but like I can't I
have higher standards now I conclude
that this is a balloon
[Music]
all right this was sent to us Nick was
saying that he didn't know how to
determine this one well this is like
actual video from inside an airplane I'm
excited about this one
I see it
I don't know what you're looking at
there's like a tiny dim black dot
[Music]
yeah it dropped Nico it changed
it
oh there it goes that's just a tiny
little blur oh
yeah I see it
it he's beginning to believe
I think this is fake I think this is
fake too the timing of the zoom Zoopa
dips down and he goes
like it seems to know where it was which
like it feels so directed the color of
the black dot feels like two black and
also here's the other thing the way it
stops and then Dives down it feels
two-dimensional to me if it actually
stopped this should happen the plane
should be flying past it and then it
goes down but it actually just stops all
in like two-dimensional screen space
almost as if it's like parented to the
the camera I need a frame by frame on
the first pass I'm going to study the
motion blur and I'm going to study the
moment it crosses in front of the plane
okay hold on hold on next frame
extreme
next stream okay what do you see Nico
what was that all right so when you're
going to do a two-dimensional animation
on a screen and something like after
effects you can turn on motion blur if
you don't set it up completely correctly
the size of the motion blur can be too
long for how far the thing should be
moving so like let's say in one frame an
object is here the next frame is here if
there is to be motion blur that motion
blur streak could not be any bigger than
the streak from this point to this point
right and what I'm kind of seeing here
is that the motion blur blur length of
that object is so long that for each
frame it's overlapping itself just a
little bit oh really okay on top of that
there's no motion blur on the cockpit as
it jumps from here to here in one frame
because we're looking at a really bright
shot with like a phone camera so the
shutters can be really really Slim that
little object moving that same distance
across the screen should be just as
crisp as the cockpit window yeah so this
is fake this is totally fake somebody
tried to trick us they did a really good
job getting either filming up an
airplane or getting a friend to film
this the compositing is really well done
the motion tracking is great and you
what they had to do an impossible move
hi I just want to tell you real quick
and admit this to you
this is my UFO video
and you did it you debunked it
I made one but I didn't know this was it
how'd you get the footage my stepdad
flies planes whenever he sees uh passing
planes on the radar he pulls out his
phone and he wants to like photograph
the planes as they're flying by when he
like goes across and then Zooms in is he
actually trying to like zoom in on
something he's just waiting for that
plane to come by so I carefully made
sure to cut it right before you start
seeing the actual playing that he's
photographing interesting well I mean
you guys called it either way so
congratulations to you yeah you're
clearly expert bunkers yeah we got to
the right answer the wrong way so
yep all done thank you story around Matt
doing that is a much larger story than
what we're putting in this video but you
can check out that full story on
quarterdigital.com he may have actually
had the best shot of all of these today
yeah yeah we know you're out there
searching and if you have anything to
send us you can send it to debunk at
Corridor digital.com if you enjoy
I highly recommend checking out the
project loom video it's the most insane
reveal in a debunking video we've done
yet link for that right here keep
watching it it'll be a fun time